i invited 100 random minecraft players
to this server and whichever one of
these people mines 1 million blocks
first gets
30 000 but what we didn't know is that
it would take over
100 hours of non-stop mining to find a
winner
drop the gates they're mining all the
leafs the easiest thing to mine
apparently if you make an iron hole in
minecraft you can tear through leaves
like it's nobody's business
just look at how fast this graph is
growing from only breaking leaves
gk41 is in the lead now gk so far
you're in first place that's uh is your
strat to just mine one million leaves
leaves leaves leaves yeah that's it wait
jimmy why are we talking to gk he's not
in first anymore
later oh i told him in the free game to
mine as many blocks as they could but i
didn't tell them what the goal was
i'm gonna join their call
i didn't tell you guys this beforehand
but the first person to mine
i love you thank you the first person to
mine one million blocks gets thirty
thousand dollars thirty thousand whoever
has the best strategy wins
oh first thousand someone hit their
thousand already
sherry you're in first place do you
think you're gonna win probably not but
at least i can keep the lead for now you
do realize this is probably gonna take
you an entire week
i'll go till it's over a lot of people
are doing the good old shears versus
leave strat that's a short-term play in
my opinion
we ran some code and there's only 1.7
million leaves on the entire map
if you divide all the leaves amongst all
the players there's only 17
000 leaves per player so they're gonna
quickly have to find a new strategy
this is lasher currently in first place
once the top players reach 10 000 blocks
everyone got so frustrated that they
started chasing
them around to slow him down what's he
gonna do is he gonna try to lava bucket
oh he is lasher welcome to the call
oh hello you maintained first place
while dodging someone trying to kill you
i had a feeling that we're trying to do
that
you're just over one percent done what's
going through your mind i got school
i don't think i'm gonna be the first
person to hit a million i can give it my
best shot
last year stayed in the lead for a few
hours but players started getting
creative with their strategy
some players in the top 10 started
looking for diamonds and geared up early
for the long game while others were
recruiting people to team up with and
finding diamonds and enchanting
materials
we are now a few hours into the
competition and someone built this house
lasher hello it's been hours and you're
still in first place
think about it this way every single
block you've mined up to this point you
would get a dollar for it is that crazy
that is insane keep digging don't stop
oh what do you want to lose first place
you just hate 30 grand in second places
i am argo at 30
000 blocks and in third place is momo
monkey with about the same they're both
about 2 000 blocks away from first place
this challenge is far from over argo
welcome to the chat
hello hi you're in second place what's
going through your mind i'm gonna go the
first
maybe hey let's go hey if you can guess
the number i'm thinking of i'll give you
this another right hook
36. i wasn't thinking of any numbers
so argo this might go on for days are
you prepared i mean i have an exam
on saturday so i don't know are you
gonna study tonight
no good play minecraft and win yo wait
wait someone's trying to kill volvo wait
what he doesn't want to win he just
wants to ruin other people's chance
robert killer why were you trying to
kill momo monkey 05
i don't like monkeys fair enough wait
there's one right beside you right now
yeah there's another monkey
oh robert jump in the water robert
you're clearly not in the top 10
leaderboard you have zero shot at
winning the 30 grand
yeah your family probably is gonna hate
you yeah i know robert killer
if you kill the person first place i'll
give you five grand i guess i have to
murder someone
go find him and due to the sheer amount
of players in this challenge we had our
mods modern to them
and also asked them what their
strategies were i think my play time is
about 1.7 days
i go to one location replan go spawn go
to another location replant there
that's kind of what i've been trying to
do being just a psychiatrist i might
have insomnia
kind of works in my favor in this
situation we officially crossed the
50-hour mark over two days of digging
all these people right here are sharing
your chest surprisingly there's stuff in
here that hasn't been stolen
maybe gamers can come together yo guys
guys streets here
irish stream ah top of the morning to
you speed running
it's your mortal enemy technoblade this
is the gentleman
currently in first place you're
destroying second place what is going on
got the efficiency showers first how
confident are you that you're gonna win
like 50 50.
that's not very confident at all seeing
how you have 160 000 block lead i
may or may not have to put a one-time
bounty on your head everybody
attention mr beast mr beast
congratulations on surviving 50 hours
as a reward we're gonna turn on pvp have
fun
first person to kill argo gets
five thousand dollars oh he's going oh
they're on the move
we got our first hunter he wants money
he might win
oh he's running he knows there's no
chance
oh no argo has a gapple you're in second
place and you literally just lost
everything
uh yeah why would you go after him
without hiding your stuff
because i thought he was so low i didn't
know he had his teammates with him i
also didn't know that argo had a
teammate named subscribe mr peace so i
put a 5 000
bounty on him as well subscribe to mr
beast is here yo
everyone's swarming everybody's too
scared to go against him the entire
server's following him
he's busting out a gamble he's busting
out a gap oh oh wait more people are
coming in oh my gosh it's gonna happen
oh there it is meteoros bros you killed
imr goat how did you do it
i spent 10 minutes trying to log into
the server i just immediately went to
spawn
just tried to kill him so that means you
get five thousand
dollars oh my god so what are you doing
go kill the other one go go
go go okay all right
this is crazy they built a freaking
pyramid and a bridge
this is a mining contest not a building
one and by the way in fourth place is a
player i'm calling one q
his strategy was probably the smartest
one on the entire server the player
count of the server dropped really low
so we decided to open it back up to the
public and a lot of new people joined
one of which was one cue one cube you
joined late you literally joined this
competition
eight hours later than everyone else but
if you look at the graph
you quickly started to catch up i went
ahead and started building a platform
and a bunch of people found my tree
phone so to help me out and just kept
expanding and expanding
all the new players formed an alliance
called team trees and they were
determined to take down argo we have
almost half the server helping us out go
find some leads hurry i wanna at least
get top three to show that what our
efforts did augur was holding a very
steady first place lead over frank they
made progress while having a five
thousand dollar bounty on their head
that's pretty impressive what is argo
gonna give you of that money i mean
you're slaving away helping him he's
gotta share with you yeah i'm gonna get
one third we'll go help him these two
guys were unstoppable
literally around 20 people were
constantly hunting argo and subscribed
mr beast but their armor and weapons
were so overpowered that they just
couldn't take him down
until this happened
how does that make you feel that
basically everyone turned on you guys
it was rough meanwhile krang was mining
away peacefully with a friend helping
him out
as you can see crank started catching up
fast i'm so
motivated right now like i'm actually
gaining on him what does your family
think of this challenge
my mom she signed me up as sick for
school your mom signed you up as sick so
you can mine blocks in this challenge
yes 95 hours has passed them just look
how close it is
but argo was missing something huge argo
was missing
an alliance late into the game one queue
and all of team trees decided that they
were on krang's side
one q why did you decide to team with
crank well i'll go stole from us i
didn't want to help out i'll go
he stole from team trees yeah he stole
xp and some other tools let's go
let's go
and they were doing whatever they could
to help crank and stop others from
building around him
craig passed argo that's so close
3k 3k 999 000 is only a thousand bucks
left
500 left come on
let's go frank got the dub argo the
challenge was
so close and you came up just short
you're in luck because we're gonna give
you
twenty thousand dollars for coming in
second oh
that's a lot of words we can't put in
the video great congratulations on
winning 30
000 i have so much adrenaline it's
honestly crazy so over the course of the
four days how much did you sleep
10 hours in total i mean it paid off
right can you 360 no skill for outro
okay bye